[Applause]
okay
here we are on overtime
uh these are the questions from people
uh is oh we wanted to talk about this on
the show i'm glad somebody asked this is
florida's don't say gay bill
designed to trap democrats into saying
they support teaching young children
about sexuality
is the question but we can broaden that
to anything about that i mean i was
reading about it today
it's uh
it's i mean if people don't know this is
something desantis is about to sign
and i guess it's a reaction to
republicans who feel that there's too
much talk in lower grades i think it's
only they're talking about kindergarten
to third grade so we're talking about
very young kids
who you know as always with this stuff
you know this
it's not like there's no kernel of truth
in that maybe kids that young shouldn't
be thinking about sex at all i i don't
think it's
specific i think don't say it it's not
like you're not allowed to literally not
say gay but they they just don't want
teachers talking about it they think
it's the province of paris what do you
think what do you think frank i'm
curious
i mean
that sounds reasonable on the face of it
i mean i'm not i'm not
my main concern as a gay man who
advocates for gay rights is not that
second graders know who harvey milk is
that is not the key
uh that is a key to lgbtq equality but
but i mean i i also question i mean does
this really need to be at the top of
these politicians list i mean this is a
total
it's this is no it's a wedges this is
this is
this is not this is not going to improve
floridians lives this is not an urgent
problem this is a dodge it's another
culture war that's meant to score cheap
easy points rather than really solving
americans problems that's right well
you disagree i disagree a little bit
yeah a little bit i think that um
i think that there is a class element to
this i'm sorry bill i'm gonna do what
you just you're you just accuse
everybody of doing which is bringing
their favorite thing
you're not gonna talk about bitcoin not
bitcoin okay this this seat eject if you
talk about bitcoin you go like oh then
talk about bitcoin
no i think that um that republicans are
trying to position themselves as um
first of all the party of the working
class which is a little bit facetious
although few are making inroads on
economic issues but also the party of
like everyday americans average
americans and parents people who are not
going to let pare you know who are going
to represent parents who say we deserve
to have a say in our child's education
and whether they go to school and what
they're taught in school and i don't
think that that's really a culture war
battle or a wedge issue parents are a
constituency like the working class who
deserve to have
that representation so i don't know if
this i read the bill also but seriously
do we know that this was an enormous
problem no pervasive in florida schools
no but like th this is this wreaks to me
of something that happened on a few
occasions and has been blown in well i i
i don't i don't know about that the same
thing with the race with the crt thing
i feel like it's it's disingenuous when
the liberals say you know they're they
we just want to teach
history and like no one's against that
well i'm sure there are some [ __ ]
rednecks who are against that but most
reasonable people are not against
realistically teaching history it sounds
like you can't mention slavery they're
talking about something else that is
going on i've read too many reports too
many first-person reports from teachers
who say i can't go on teaching like this
because this is insanity what i'm doing
in this classroom separating kids by
race and oppressors and non-oppressors
and they're little kids it is going on i
don't know what is going on with the
gender as much let me read what
something what part of the bill it says
the measure would this is from cnn would
require districts to adopt procedures
for notifying a student's parent if
there was a change in the student's
services or monitoring related to the
student's
mental emotional physical health or
wealth being okay then it says something
lgbtq advocates argue
could lead to some students being outed
to their parents
that phrase
struck me as odd like outed to parents
like
shouldn't parents know everything
anyway
yeah the concept of
without that
i think that um but i think that fell
out of the bill i think that's actually
no is that well the one that i read
right before the show was that the vast
majority of the bill is about that is
about parents right to
know if their child is identifying
changing the way that they're you know
presenting if the teacher is calling
them to name this kind of thing i think
in california
it's the school has more of those rights
than the parent well that's not right
that's right that's right okay great oh
no yep
well that's not how everybody feels out
here it's like we need to protect the
student from the parents with the school
the school and yeah that's that's a
political winner
you should live out here for a while
you'll see some crazy [ __ ] okay
and yet
as i always say
the climate is a disaster and the
weather is delightful
frank you write in your book about how
we should be more open with our
vulnerabilities which you coined as the
sandwich board theory how can we create
our own sandwich boards both online and
in real life your book is fantastic by
the way thank you my friend i know my
friend carol
yeah we did an event last night yeah she
told me it was worked great uh i wish i
could have been there but i had to work
on my day job
well i don't want to explain the whole
sandwich board thing but my basic point
is that if we were all a lot more honest
about who we were who we are you know if
we showed our full selves to the world
and if we all looked for the fullness of
everyone around us we wouldn't lapse
into the caricatures that we do we
wouldn't treat people as abstractions
you know i i love the beginning of the
show i'll mention it a second time
because you all were talking about
tribalism which i think is the curse of
our times right now tribalism hinges on
us not seeing each other as fully full
full multi-dimensional fully fleshed
human beings it hinges on us seeing
everybody as either pro or khan ally or
enemy friend or foe people are more
complicated than that life is more
complicated than that and we have lost
any talent for nuance in this country
well said i can't i can't top it so i'm
going to end it right there thank you
too thank you audience you were terrific
you